si tu l'aimés de veiller elle est au
chômage
elle ne verra pas la différence au
niveau de ma tête c'est les personnes
font croire qu'elles sont ensemble mais
on n'est pas fous ils ne seront jamais
ensemble
arrêtons les mensonges et aux arêtes des
messages de troll bien supportable les
paiements sont allées très clairement qu
on n'était pas ensemble voilà une petite
bille du bisou dans des petits jobs
rapprochement l'année dernière bon je
pense que les choses ont été mises au
clair a aujourd'hui c'est daniel j'ai
rêvé que je rencontrerai castaldi et
qu'on avait donc très longues
conversations et bien je veux dire qu'il
est beaucoup pour tout de suite mais on
est toujours le con de quelqu'un et dans
mon cas ça m'a parfois aider voilà
maxime gainey réfléchit pas tranquille
vdev l'icom colloque vous vous aimez
beaucoup et vous après vous apprécie
énormément
ben écoute message tout droit pour un
maxi vieni non il ne veut pas de moi en
colocation en fait six mois que j en
parle
et voilà huit ya un petit peu radin sur
les bords ça devrait s'arranger pourtant
faudrait lui dire oh bien sûr je pense
qu'on pourrait bien vivre en colocation
avec kelly sait bien que je vis seule je
suis très bien à lui également dans son
appartement elle un petit chien moi j'ai
pas d'écraser voilà pourquoi gilles
verdez et quand même inutile à part
gueuler gueuler c'est utile parce que
gueuler quand vous avez des gens qui
disent n'importe quoi comme castaldi
delormeau benhaim mergheni bosque qui
d'autre encore tous raymond ça vaut le
coup de gueule et parce que si on gueule
pas ça veut dire qu on acquiesce alors
propos moi je préfère donner haut et
fort mon point de vue pour qu'on
m'entende
plutôt que de m'écraser voilà comme
certains
apanui fair titi qui parvient à se
défaire du team on répondra juste un
groupe de gens michel mr et un gros
dégueulasse en plus un menteur un jaloux
un groupe mike coots merci beaucoup
university alors un groupe peut-être ça
je fais des sujets je sais pas en tout
cas gros dégueulasse jaune ou pense pas
quand je me lève tous les matins et je
suis plutôt respectueux du tout à chacun
menteur rappant franchement voix lors
tout le proof et un jaloux pas du tout
#cannes matters jeté par un casting au
charismatique beau sourire je kiffe quoi
dire de plus tout est écrit mais
pourquoi tu es belle
kerry ce serait trop je ne rentrais pas
de répondre à la question alors yolo le
jour et lille uc auray la carrière de
jean michel mr tu m'appelleras c'est
très gentille l'eau mais non ils disent
que c'est une très belle carrière c'est
pas ça que j'aime beaucoup
une carrière tout à fait modeste et est
normal et c est là tout à fait alors qui
sait jamais ça que j'en manque en cause
voilà c'est seulement les méthodes
journalistiques de son émission
quatrième venir sans violence ni yen ce
qu'apporte maxime gagne la tmp
peux-tu me dire sans violence ni m à
quoi sert tout d'suite notamment de la
bienveillance tempérance et de la bonne
humeur fait déjà pas mal